I got a plan my get us both killed but
if it works it'll be a totally boss
story cool no I was not cool that's
Dwayne the rock Johnson and Kevin Hart
in the action comedy central
intelligence now they play old high
school classmates who reunite used to be
how's it been going how's the shoot bit
so far our days on set are filled with
nothing but love and appreciation here
we are shooting 60 televisions their
shutters down fire trucks around here
it's every day laughing having fun watch
your mouth okay they really are playing
with those posts but one thing they're
serious about workouts heard that you
both are in the gym early in the morning
every day who's getting it in both of us
I beat the Sun up four o'clock in the
morning right I'm crazy there's one man
on this earth one man on this earth who
does that to take my gut we may have to
kill some people who do no such thing I
think you'll like it I will not Dwayne
tag ich turn CIA agent who drags Kevin
who is a mild-mannered accountant into a
world of espionage in the movie it's the
first time that the rock is worked with
my man Kevin but here's what I want to
know when is it gonna be my turn I've
never been in one of your movies man I
don't understand I've been every set
that's crazy that's crazy you all right
you